what was the Genesis moment obviously
with some Financial enablement so you
could create a foundation that led to
you know what I'm going to put this
Foundation together because I got some
messages and I've got some assistance
that I can give these young men
uh 2008 Dirty Jobs uh is the number one
show on Discovery maybe maybe the number
one show in the network
um it certainly on the network maybe on
cable
um the show is in 180 countries and I
was doing great and everything we'd been
on five years and the country was going
into a recession
and it was shocking how how quickly you
guys will remember how oh yeah how fast
things crashed September of October of
08 thud that's well so I started micro
Works uh on Labor Day
of 2008 and I started it because wow we
were on the road in those days
living in motel sixes and super eights
and getting up every morning and you
know I'd pick up the newspaper and I'd
look at the headlines and it was just
always always always unemployment
numbers it was always how many people
are out of work and I remember watching
It Go five six six and a half seven
seven and a half eight you know over ten
percent
on dirty jobs everywhere we went
uh I saw Help Wanted signs
and so something
was happening in the country that nobody
was talking about and it had to do with
what I thought at the time was a
mismatch of skills so you had 2.3
million jobs that people couldn't seem
to hire for and these jobs by and large
didn't require a four-year degree they
they required training
and uh you know after these jobs I would
always go out and have a beer with the
people that I worked with and I always
ask them the same question and it was
always the same answer it was just we
our single biggest challenge is finding
people willing to show up early stay
late take a bite of the crap sandwich
when it comes along learn a skill that's
in demand we just can't find it couldn't
find him five years ago now it's
virtually impossible so the foundation
started
in a way now that I think about it for
the same reason I read to the blind I
wanted to do something good for somebody
other than me but I also wanted to
benefit from it to be completely honest
so it began as a PR campaign for what I
believed were a couple million
opportunities that were going unloved
right and so I wanted to talk about
those opportunities in the same way that
a dirty jobs
was designed to shine a light on humans
doing these kinds of jobs I just wanted
to look at the jobs themselves and say
hey America not for nothing but
right these guys are killing it
as plumbers and here's how you do that
so it began as a PR campaign it took me
to Congress a few times we got some
attention as a result of all that and
then some companies who were struggling
with their own recruiting challenges
came and I started working with them
because you know as you know a company
is
it's its own least persuasive Advocate
and a recruiting message is not so
different than a marketing message
and the [ __ ] meter for people today
is very very high right and so companies
do a really poor job by and large of
making a case for themselves so I became
somewhat useful to big companies and
helping them tell the story of the
opportunities that existed underneath
their own umbrellas and then um it sort
of morphed into a trade Resource Center
fans of Dirty Jobs
um helped me build an online resource
that would just direct people to zip
codes where these jobs existed and then
we would attach things to that direction
like apprenticeship programs that were
available and other ways to get the
necessary training and so forth and then
it was a scholarship fund
and uh I guess it was maybe 2012 I
started to raise money for that and
we're modest by Foundation standards but
we give away we just gave away um one
and a half million dollars in work ethic
scholarships modest six stipends right
but but they're not for kids who want to
go to a four-year School these are
specifically for people who want to get
trained for a skill that's actually in
demand and so we've been at it now 15
years and what I learned along the way
was this is making a difference in
people's lives on a on a micro level
which is awesome it's making different
in micros life which is awesome but on a
macro level it's it's it is having an
impact on the skills Gap and it is
helping shape
a broader conversation about the
definition of a good job and so we're
about seven million dollars in now
um and the biggest thing that's happened
Tom that that I that I didn't anticipate
was that the stories I tell shifted from
my own anecdotal experiences and
suspicions and beliefs about what's
going on in the workforce
to actual testimonies from a welder who
five years ago we assisted who now owns
three vans hired half a dozen people
heating air conditioning electric
plumbing has a mechanical contracting
company does a couple million dollars a
year so it's this uh Nexus of
Entrepreneurship uh a willingness to get
your hands dirty and understanding that
opportunity might not look like the
thing you were you were told it looks
like and
um
and all of that just kind of smeared
together and so the for me the great
Good Fortune is that my Foundation
Rhymes perfectly with my identity in the
industry Dirty Jobs and how America
works
are the same basic show
on two competitive Networks justified by
an underlying Foundation that actually
gives me permission to come on shows
like yours and say I think
I think you can still read to the blind
dude in a way that helps everyone the
reader
and The Listener and and that brings us
back to to ran powerful and it just
brings us back to look I
here's what I don't want any of your
listeners to be confused by I'm it's
tempting really really tempting to sit
here and say Let me let me tell you how
I did it here was the plan and here were
my action steps and here's my legacy
that I've got my eye on right none of
that happened for me it was simply put
your head down do the next job
get in the hole Crawl Through the sewer
get on the crab boat crawl up the bridge
meet the men shake their hands listen to
their stories let them be the expert and
then get out of get out of the way go to
another town do it again and
in doing that again and again
and then talking to the woman you
mentioned earlier Mary who's with me now
who's the only business partner I've
ever had never had an agent never had a
manager never had a public really yeah
how long has she been with you 18 years
damn so is that is it just business
partners it's it's I mean it's
everything okay good yeah I mean it's
not bad oh okay it's not bad but it's
it's bigger than that you know Mary and
I have uh we can communicate without
talking you know she
she was running a a really
well a boutique Law Firm representing
some really big clients and she got a
phone call from me uh from a sewer I
negotiated my own deal with Discovery
right and um in those days I negotiated
for
for failure because my business model
wasn't based on success at all it was
based on touch everything like it's hot
I was a freelancer I had 100 jobs a year
by and large I wasn't looking for a hit
and uh so I shrewdly negotiated my own
deal which gave them the right to do
whatever they wanted in the Advent or in
the event of success of course there was
no success you know in my mind there's
no way anybody's going to watch the show
anyhow it blew up
and I needed help so I I found her and
and so yeah she looks at a release and
says hey have you thought about this I
said oh okay maybe I should think more
we all need people like that Victoria or
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]